[Music]
2007's coming-of-age comedy Superbad
provided a treasure trove of one-liners
hilarious moments and unforgettable
characters but it's hard to argue that
there's anyone more iconic than the fake
ID Sporting uber geek McLovin the role
even earned Ben 17 year old actor
Christopher mintz-plasse an MTV Movie
Award nominee performance while super
bad certainly helped springboard some of
its actors on to bigger and better
things we haven't seen too much immense
blast lately let's find out what adult
McLovin looks like today I am club in
man becoming Fishlegs not many people
realize that mintz-plasse is a prominent
voice in the How to Train Your Dragon
franchise in 2010's action fantasy
mintz-plasse voiced the enthusiastic
Fishlegs a young Viking whose bulky body
appears in sharp contrast to the actor
skinny McLovin voice hi I'm Fishlegs
clearly not enough mintz-plasse digs
doing voice work for family-friendly
fair telling hyperbole I love it man
it's exciting because most of my movies
are rated R and I go in there and I'm
trying to make kids laugh so it's cool
to do a PG movie and you can go in
wearing sweatpants and do it kick ass
moves mintz-plasse is second most famous
role is that of superhero turned
supervillain Chris read miss D'Amico in
kick ass and kick ass too that is until
his character changed his name
henceforth I'll be known as
some mother the big screen role was
actually written with mintz-plasse in
mind but the actor thinks the original
character from the Marvel comic is
cooler he told cinema blend he's much
cooler than I am
they wanted my father to be a badass and
I've never been accepted by him they
wanted that instead of the cool guy
who's always smoking weed and getting
the girls nevertheless the role landed
mintz-plasse a nomination at the 2010
Teen Choice Awards Hollywood remake in
2011 mintz-plasse landed the role of
evil idli in the comedic remake of
1985's horror flick Fright Night really
hate to be the one to tell you this but
that guy your neighbour Jerry he's a
vampire originally mintz-plasse wasn't
feeling a reboot but he couldn't pass up
the chance to work with Collin Farrel
mintz-plasse told HitFix I'm not the
biggest fan of mice cuz you know I sit
and watch the trailers oh my gosh think
of a new freaking idea you know but he
was on board once he saw the cast list
and I saw the Anton and Colin and gray
and Craig were all attached if done
right it could be this really memorable
role for the movie almost a sitcom star
in 2012 mintz-plasse was on track to
have his own TV series friend me written
by writer Alan Kirschenbaum
unfortunately friend me was cancelled
after Kherson mom passed away
mintz-plasse tweeted r.i.p alan only
worked with you for 10 days but thanks
so much for this wonderful job you were
a funny great guy but mintz-plasse
landed on TV for real when he booked
2016's the Great Indoors
it is so incredible to meet you on Clark
online content curator hi Clark
obviously made-up job title while the
show was cancelled after just one season
mintz-plasse his performance proved he
could be sitcom gold in the right part
musically inclined mintz-plasse has
appeared in a slew of music videos
perhaps most notably he played drums in
Kid Cudi's late 60s inspired erase me
mintz-plasse also appeared alongside
kick-ass co-star Chloe grace Moretz for
the soft packs answer to yourself as
well as unknown Mortal orchestras so
good at being in trouble most recently
he starred as a kidnapper in Alice in
Wonderland's you don't know and a man
who overcomes life in a wheelchair in
coda lines ready
rocking out mintz-plasse isn't just
music video I can he's also in a band
after playing drums for young rasp
scallions for eight years before they
broke up
mintz-plasse and his friend Adam a
seraph say they started getting high
jamming out in the backyard and calling
themselves bear on fire when they
realized that things were getting groovy
the duo recruited some friends and
released their first studio album in
2015
though shottsford McLovin inevitably
followed the actor wherever he plays
mintz-plasse doesn't mind he told
Stereogum I just want as many people to
come to the show and as many people to
hear my music as possible going dark
when it comes to future work
mintz-plasse is most interested in
darker more dramatic roles however going
dark in the kick-ass series wasn't the
easiest thing for the actor he told the
Belfast Telegraph I read the script and
I was nervous because it's unlike
anything I've ever done before
so I got an acting coach a month before
filming we would go through every scene
in every line and figure out where the
character needed to go emotionally
mintz-plasse also studied some other
villainous characters from the big
screen to help him get it right and some
from real life too he said I watched
Heath Ledger's Joker quite a bit and I
researched Marvel's The Punisher I also
watched this really dark serial killer
on trial I studied his eyes and how
lifeless they were and tried to use that
too a far cry from McLovin innocent baby
face but these days he truly wants to
kick some ass thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
you